eSports are a battle of wits a grueling
mentally exhausting emotionally taxing
endeavor where the difference between
success and failure is often decided by
your ability to outsmart your opponent
Guardian cannot be stopped he picks up
another killer now it's down to Russia
one on two has to clutch it again fnatic
they're really really having issues and
there's no rush here for Guardian
guardian does not have to play
aggressively here flusher are you
kidding me Russia this is so intelligent
no he no one's gonna check here he's
waiting he wants to know where starix is
flush it is playing a masterful game
this is the absolute highest level of
Counter Strike right now
beautiful beautiful round one flush yeah
he deserves to get this he's gonna walk
out Guardian has no idea therefore kill
they wished it so much time flush he may
have just done him it's gonna go down
there's no time he did it anyway
such intelligent play here from the
Swedish player but sometimes the battle
can be won before it's even fought and
that can be seen in the pick/ban systems
employed in many of today's biggest
competitive games looking at the draft
after looking at the draft we in our
experts opinion which I don't know if it
agrees with a panel or not but we're
gonna basically say c9 if they don't win
the first five minutes it's over it's
over it's just sorry about that oh
there's nothing more to be done
same thing got a nice cold lock but
again even the middle of an entire
lineup of DK that forty pretty damn
patents and one of them being a flat
striking
this is dragsters mecha really finished
living every word morality and he's
gonna jump back out the wolf she never
stops he's going for the kill
change them come through mp's gonna go
down I think no he's gonna walk out of
there in 14 seconds the G team will come
down from cloud 9 here in game them in
search gained double one day it's for
the marathon game number 2 is over
before it started
so where did the pick/ban format that
were so familiar with come from well the
modern pick/ban system can actually be
traced back to 2007 and the early days
of MOBAs with the original dota the
motives called extended league and was
enabled by entering the abbreviated
command excel want you to get in there
and I want you to go get me some ratings
no Excel not the XFL was shocked stunned
dazed confused anyway Excel was added to
dota in March 2007 with patch 6.43 as a
rework of the previous league mode Excel
added bands to league mode allowing both
Sentinel and scourge sides to remove
three heroes from the opposition's pool
of potential characters the mode was
played at both Dreamhack summer 2007 and
the wcl dota league but it was captain's
mode added in patch 6.55 in October 2008
that gave us the format that we still
largely use today team captains would
alternate bands then pick in a 1 to 2 2
to 1 format players could then choose
from the heroes their team drafted this
configuration with some tweaks would
become a mainstay in basically every
MOBA to follow such as draft pick in
League of Legends banning pick in Heroes
of Newerth and of course captain's mode
in dota 2 even games from other genres
would also develop pick/ban systems of
their realm
typically for map selection pick band
formats became popular for a number of
reasons
the first is that for the casual player
you could simply ban things
you don't want to come up against like
Yasuo in League of Legends a lot of
people want me dead as they should you
piece of [__] seriously
Bucky osawa and [__] Yasuo means I'm not
alone on this either in competitive play
the pick/ban system not only led to more
tactically driven comp building but it
also inspired all sorts of innovations
facing elimination if they lose this
match 12:9 is going home you need some
damage you meet some teamfight electron
sings solomid kunkka's yeah that's a
good cool me pop eyes back you want to
come in this fight they retreat it's
gonna be even from envy and it's all up
to them to save Sylar meatball it's
gonna find FY you can be dead
how much more can to get clockwork he
fries super that yields that sense of oh
he's gonna survive her a little longer
and he gets blown up
rabbit comes in the zipper
the ghost will not come back and not
going for the towers back inside the
time face they're already through on the
cheap pause
[Applause]
the portrait
keep themselves in it with the meat part
pick on top of tactically opening games
up pick bans also took mind games to a
whole new level
you hate techies I do hate techies a lot
so there we go
when the heroes in the game only he's
having fun that's how I feel water and
did you have fun playing of course he's
super fun
well techies picks up one cheeky that's
be skilled bloodseeker goes down see
that kissing you're gonna play around us
we're gonna make but as with most things
in life mistakes are made every day you
never know what they're gonna do he's
got a husband in a champ select in a
while he forgets oh this comes through
[Applause]
butterfly I'd be careful about this TiVo
hovers man I mean that cannot come back
to haunt you this season yeah that was
dodgy yesterday with what huh are you
serious
one eternity later alright is what it is
well it's been done but now it's over
now we can move on to Game three the
definitely a real game of week legends
it has been tough now your motto papi
jungle is not something we've seen in a
very long time in the EU LCS what made
you pick it up here in a title match I
actually [__] up with the first pick
in the 2001 NBA Draft the Washington
Wizards select for me Brown
[Applause]
okay that last one wasn't eSports but it
still counts as a drafting mistake Kwame
Brown Kwame Brown Kwame Brown this man
was a bonafide scrub he can't play and
it's this cerebral strategic aspect of
pick/ban that has increasingly become a
staple for newer eSports titles some
even outside the MOBA genre Rainbow six
siege which combines elements of both
traditional FPS games and class-based
ones added a band system in 2018 and it
makes a lot of sense because there are
operators in the game who completely
reshape how combat unfolds denying
threats like this from even stepping
foot on the battlefield forces teams to
deploy varying strategies for all sorts
of situations and of course the pick/ban
system is an excellent tool for
developers to gather information about
the state of their games balance if a
character is widely considered to be
overpowered then more often than not
it's going to get banned
more recently in siege the operator lion
has been quarantined from pro play
pending revisions to his kit as a result
of his overwhelmingly high band Rage a
product of his oppressive global ability
that hugely impacts how the game is
played at the highest level this is
Venice
and this brings us to 2019 where another
popular class based shooter is
increasingly facing calls from some fans
to add band's overwatch at the
competitive level the game has been
somewhat limited by dominant metas but
imagine how much tactical diversity
there could be if banning key heroes to
divert goats team columns was on the
table so far there hasn't been any
movement from Blizzard and while they've
said in the past that they've considered
it they don't feel like a band system
would be a good fit for the game whether
you're for or against the pick/ban phase
it's hard to argue that it hasn't
contributed a unique added level of
psychology and strategy to some of the
eSports we know and love for sure but
you could avoid it by just playing
characters that fly under the radar like
recruit sure he does his ability is that
he can't be banned you know a lot of
people say I'm [__] tier but the truth
is I'm actually Opie I mean who's better
I've got a famas and a sweet ski mask
what about tachanka no comment see I
rest my case
does that sound like something I do they
had that forum post something stupid
happened is legendary in the CS
community and your reading of something
stupid happened is the definitive
reading it might be the only one but
regardless I anybody to produce a better
reading of something stupid happen than
you did nobody can if you're watching
this [__] try it
miles is reading is gonna be better than
yours you know what send us your reading
of something stupid happened put in the
comments all right I like I like to see
some effort but I think miles is gonna
dunk on you guys anyways
[Music]